alors michèle torr l'amour a toujours
tenu une grande place dans votre vie
dans vos chansons vous êtes la cliente
idéale pour une interview
par amour
oui est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à tout arrêter de chanter par
amour du public
on met déjà lui même pas s'il me dit ça
je me demande ça me le demandait ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à prendre 17
kilos mais je crois que c'est quoi
est-ce que par amour richy prête à vous
mettre à la drogue en pétard ça fait pas
trop mal
est-ce que vous en soyez pas tu as
changé de chemisiers est-ce que par
amour question clotilde courau là vous
seriez prête à embrasser cent fois ses
chaussettes sales par amour oui un peu
con là dans votre programme
est-ce que par un nouveau soyez prêtes à
accepter quelques petites infidélités
par mois ben tiens le coup c'est assez
vous ça le rendre ma wii sont souvent le
rôle dans les po à paris mais ouais vous
exacte du mal à accepter
c'est arrivé ça peut arriver est-ce que
par amour vous accepteriez c'est plus
grave qu'il ait deux maîtresses non non
non non à nous maintenant
non non non non même s'ils se rendre
ouais non mais
comme ça tu en entends une erreur oui
non je vous demande pas si par amour ou
seriez prête à vivre à trois avec la
maîtresse non j'aurais beaucoup de mal
des morts aller tous les trois dans un
club échangiste lycée michel ettorre
quand eddie emmène moi danser ce soir ce
qui rajoute dans un club échangiste nous
suffit d'écouter les discours c'est pas
compliqué est-ce que par amour
je suis je prête à devenir sa super
esclaves sexuelles quelques oeufs n'ont
jamais vu à part isabelle alonso
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
changer de sexe si vous l'aimez
il vous aime et vous disent qu'ils
aiment voilà je t'aime et si tu m'aimes
vraiment devient un homme pour moi dans
une autre vie et la mort